[موسيقى]
على اكبر حدث رياضيا
خاصه في بعض الدول اوروبا الغربيه
وشككت في قدرته على تنظيم هذه البطوله
العالميه لكنها كشفت في الوقت نفسه جهله
بعض وسائل الاعلام الغربيه بثقافه هذه
المنطقه وقيامها الاخلاقيه والحضاريه
واظهرت المستوى الذي يمكن ان تنزل اليه في
اطلاق العنان لاحكامها المسبقه والنمطيه
عن كل ما هو عربي مسلم من جانب الاخر سلطت
حمله التشكيك والتشهير الضوء على
الاشكالات الثقافيه بين الشرق والغرب
وفضحت ثقافه الاستعلام لدى بعض الاطراف
التي تريده تكريس الصوره السلبيه عن العرب
وفرض رؤيته عليهم بدل اغتنام فرصه العرس
الكروي الكبير لفتح افاق الحوار بين
الثقافات المختلفه والتقري بوجهه النظر
بين الشعوب فما هو الارث الذي سيتركه
مونديال قطر على مستوى الجدل المثار بشان
الاشكلات المرتبطه بالقيم والهويه والى اي
حد نجح في تغيير المفاهيم الخاطئه والصور
النبطيه السلبيه عن العرب التي داب
الاعلام الغربي على ترويشها اهلا بكم في
هذه الحلقه من سيناريوهات
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
الايام الاولى لانطلاق مباريات كاس العالم
وحتى قبل ذلك بكثير تعرضت قطر لشتى اصناف
الدعايه والشحن الاعلامي في محاوله يائسه
للتشويش وتعكير الاجواء وفرض قيم
الاخلاقيه غريبه عن ثوابت هذه المنطقه لم
يسبق ان اثارت بطوله عالميه لكره القدم
جدلا بمثل ما اثارته هذه النسخه الاخيره
من كاس العالم لكن عشاق كره القدم الذين
قدموا من كل حد وصوب راو غير ما سمعوه في
وسائل اعلاميه
عن هذا الجدل وخلفياته وما تبقى منه بعد
انتهاء العرس الكروي يسعدنا ان يكون معنا
في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو الدكتور
نايف بالنهار مدير مركز ابن خلدون للعلوم
الانسانيه والاجتماعيه من الرباط الدكتور
حسن اوريد استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
محمد الخامس ومن ميونخ الدكتور جيرماس
كانتر استاذ العلاقات السياسيه الالمانيه
الشرق اوسطيه
انتهت اذن بطوله كاس العالم مسجله ارقام
جديده على مستوى الحضور الجماهري
والمشاهدات والعائدات الماليه مع اشاد
دوليه بحسن التنظيم بدايه من حفل الافتتاح
الى الاقدام اما الزوار والمشجعون فعادوا
محملين بذكريات ستبقى محفوره في ادهانهم
بعد ان اطلعوا عن قرب على العادات
والتقاليد العربيه وتعرفوا على الخصوصيات
الثقافيه للمنطقه التي حاولت بعض وسائل
الاعلام وافراد من الطبقه السياسيه في
الغرب عن جهل او اجندات خفيه تنسها او
تشويها مع لمها الحقيقيه
[موسيقى]
نرحب بضيوفنا ثلاثه ونبدا بالدكتور نائب
بالنهار اهلا وسهلا بك
بين كل ما استعرضناه في هذا التقرير ما هي
المساله التي يجب فعلا ان نتوقف عندها
يعني
الاشكاليات كلها هي في السودان
اوروبا
التي دائما كانت تفتخر بعقلانيتها في
التعامل مع المشهد الثقافي الدولي حينما
جاء كاس العالم تغير الامر وتعامله
بالهويه بدل من تعاملها بالعقلانيه
المسائل التي ذكرت قبل قليل في التقرير
الشدود الجنسي سواء اللبس
لا علاقه لها بالقيم الاوروبيه ولا علاقه
لها بفكر التنوير ولا علاقه لها بما يتعلق
بحقوق الانسان فلماذا غضب الانسان
الاولمبي لماذا غضبها هؤلاء من اشياء لا
تمش القيم الاوروبيه في شيء ولا تمسح حقوق
الانسان في شيء هذه يدل ان المساله اساسا
اشكاليتها تعود الى ان الاوروبي يتعامل
معنا بمنطقه الهويه وليس بمنطقه العقلانيه
وهذا ما جعله يركز على قضايا النص هويته
اكثر يعني تلاحظ الغضب الذي رايناه على
مسائل مثل الشذوذ الجنسي والغيره لماذا لا
نرى نفس هذا الغضب قضايا اكبر موجوده في
العالم العربي نحن في العالم العربي نعاني
من نقص في قضايا كبرى على مستوى غياب
سياده القانون وغياب الحقوق الاساسيه
وغياب الحريات السياسيه وغياب استقلال
القضاء وغير من هذه القضايا لكن لم تسمع
اي شخص يتكلم عن هذه القضايا كان هذه
الشعوب ليس لها حقوق الحقوق الوحيد التي
انتبهوا لها هي الحقوق التي تمسه هويتهم
بما انه يتم الان تعبر وترضى بهذه الامور
فهم يريدون الثقافات الاخرى ايضا تشكل
امتدادا لهويته اما القضايا الاخرى لم
يتعرض لها وهذه يدل على انهم لم يتعاملوا
همم هذه المسائل تعامل عقلانيا يعبر عما
يروج له من ان ال- ال- ال- الجانب
الاوربيه بشكل عام هو يعتمد على العقلانيه
وهذا بشكل
عن التفريق بين الحقوق الثقافيه والحقوق
الانسانيه يعني لما الان نمنع الشدود
الجنسي وهو يقول لا هذا يعرض حقوق الانسان
من قال انه يعرض حقوق الانسان بمعيار من
اصبح الشذوذ حقها انت تراه حقا لكن هناك
اربع مليارات او خمسه مليارات على وجه هذه
الارض لا يرون حقا فلماذا انت اختيارك
لكونه حقا جعله حقا من هذه الناحيه الامر
واضح انه في تعبير على الهويه لذلك
الاوروبي لا يريد ان يناقشنا في هذه
المساله وانا كنت في قنوات عديده في
القنوات الاوروبيه دائما كنت تطرح هذا
السؤال من الذي يحدد لنا ما هو حق الانسان
انتم حددتوا ان الشدود حق الانسان نحن هنا
لا نرضى نحن مثلا نقول تعدد الزوجات تعدد
الزوجات ينظر له في العالم العربي على انه
حق من الحقوق الاوروبي ولا يرضونه هو
ممنوع في القانون الاوروبي طيب نحن لماذا
هم لا ينظرون الى حقل الى تعدد الزوجات
على انه حق من حقوق الانسان هم هذه
الانتقائيه هم احرار فيها في بلدانهم لكن
المشكله في تعميم العقل الاوروبي على بقيه
العالم في جعل الانسان الغربي او الاوروبي
تحديد او الغرب الاوروبي تحديدا او الشمال
الاوروبي تحديدا هو الذي يمثل البشريه
كلها هذه المساله هذه اذا اذا نظرنا
للمساله من هذه الناحيه سنفهم كل ما حصل
في كاس العالم انه صراع على مستوى الهويات
مهما تحدثت اوروبا على انها تجاوزت مساله
الهويه في الحقيقه انها لم تتجاوز بدا
الامر مع الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
حينمائين العنصريه الاوروبيه والتحيز
للهويه الاوروبيه كان غالبا على التحيز
للهويه الانسانيه وامتد هذا الامر الى
رايناه فاكعا في مستوى كاس العالم
الى
المفردات الاوروبيه اكثر من مره هنا اسال
الدكتور في ميونخ اهلا وسهلا بك لماذا هذه
المساله تحديدا هي في اوروبا الغربيه ربما
بدرجه اخص يعني لم نشهد هذا الاشكال مع
امريكا الشماليه مع امريكا اللاتينيه مع
دول اسيا ما الذي جعل اوروبا الغربيه
تحديدا تحت كر بين قوسين مثل هذا الجدل
نعم
جزء من التفسير هو كيف تعمل اله الاعلام
واليات الاعلام فكان من السهل عليها ان
تعتنقه الصور النبطيه الجاهزه بدلا من
اتخاذ نظره اكثر والتواصل هذا لا يعني
بالضروره الانحياز الى طرف لكن لم يكن
هناك حاجه ان نظهر انتقادا للامور نظرنا
فقط بل كان ينبغي ان نرى الصوره الاكمل
وان لمده صوره بين الحضارات المختلفه ربما
هناك تفسير اخر لان هناك شخصيه لبعض
السياسيين
بيحدد ذاتهم من الذين يستطيعون كسب اصوات
الناخبين لصالحهم في اوروبا من خلال
الترويج لبعض التقاليد الثقافيه هنا ارى
حقيقه ان هناك خطارا ماحقا من
طرح هذه الامور على
التقديم
المعطيات
والموجبات الداخليه فوق اعتبارات السياسه
الخارجيه العلاقات
في كثير من وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
العام العربي هو ان الدول الغربيه حره في
القيم التي تريد ان تتبنى هذا لا يشارك
فيه او لا يجادل فيه احد المشكله هو اللي
ماذا تريد هذه الدول ان تجعل هذه القيم
بالضروره معتنقه من قبل الجميع
واساسا ربما العرب والمسلمين
امين
بعد انتهاء الحرب البارده
مليارات من البشر في العالم يختلفون
وثقافاتهم في ثقافتهم وقيامهم ورائهم
وكل واحده من مراكز القوى هذه
يستفيدنا سواء كانوا قاده في مجال المال
والاعمال او السياسه ان يفهم هذه الامور
ويقبلوها بدلا من من محاوله فرض قيامهم
ومعتقداتهم وان يملوا على الاخرين ان
يفعلوا ما يفعلوه كما قلتم انتم بحق هناك
كل طرف يرى ما يراه مناسبا له هو بامكانك
ان تخبر الاخرين بهذا لكن لا تتوقع منهم
على او تكرههم على اتباعها على الاقل يمكن
ان نتناقش معهم في ذلك البعض ذلك همم
الدكتور حسن
ريد راه ينمو عن جهل من قبل الاعلام
الغربي والراي العام الغربي بهذه المنطقه
البعض الاخر راه لا هو تنميط به نظره نظره
استعداد تخفي قناعات استعماريه قديمه لم
لم تتخلص منها هذه القاره كيف رايتها انت
اول شيء حينما نتحدث عن هذا الموضوع ينبغي
ان نقر باننا نتحدث بعد العقاد المونديال
ونجاح المونديال الحديث عن
عن المرج قبل المونديال وابنائه شيئا اخر
نحن الان نتحدث عن تظاهره نجحت ولقد
اقبالا كبيرا منقطع النظير بشهاده
العارفين وغير العارفين ثانيا نحن نتحدث
عن ظاهره رياضيه ليست سياسيه ولا ثقافيه
وكان احرى بكل الذين شاركوا ان يحترموا
هذا التابع وثالث انه في تاريخ المونديال
لم يسبق لدوله ان غيرت لغتها او قيمها
قطار لم تغير قواعد لعبه كره القدم يحترمت
كل القواعد ومن حقها بل من يواجه بها ان
تحافظ على قيامها حقيقه ماراج قبل همم
المونديال اثناء المونديال وبعده يثير
كثير من الاسئله حول هذه النظره همم
وحريم بنا طبعا ان نتساءل هل هو جهل ام
تجاوب ويبدو لي بانه
تجاهل اكثر ونظره نمطيه ووو وس- واستعلاء
الذي يمكن
ان يقال هو ان هذه يعني تخرسات يعني لم
تعد مفيده يعني لانه المونديال نجح يعني
وبقدر ما اثار كثير من
الانتقادات يعني اثار كذلك موجه من
التضامن او ردود فعل يمكن ان نعتبرها
ايجابيا طبعا نحن الان في وضعها ينبغي
معالجه الامر او التصدي له برويه ما الذي
يدفع بعضا من اصحاب وصانع الراي يعني ان
يزج باحكام قيمه واحكام همم مسبقه وهذا
حقيقه لا ربما يرتبط مثل ما قلت بمخلفات
ماضيه قد ترتبط بالماضي الاستعماري لكل
دوله ولكل امه
حافظه عن قيامها ما دام في نهايه المطاف
انها لا تؤثر ولا تمس همم
المجتمعات الاخرى
وحقيقه همم
المواقف التي عبرت عنها بعد همم
يعني القنوات واصحاب الراي يعني همم لا
تدخل في خانه حريه الراي ولا تدخلوا همم
في همم
اطار يعني همم
المسؤول يعني تدخل في اطار التحامل ربما
كان مثل ما قال الاستاذ نايف انه كان حريا
بهؤلاء ان يطرحوا قضايا مرتبطه بهذه
المجتمعات وكثيره هي القضايا التي حقيقه
تستحق على اعتبار انه يعني نحن في ولو
اننا نحن في اطار تظاهره الرياضيه لكن
الزوج بقضايا يعني مثيره اخلاقيه وليست من
الاولويات هذا يعني ينمو عن همم عن تعالي
واستفزاز لا مكان له في نهايه المطاف قرات
مؤخرا بان قناه اعتذرت
همم
دنماركي يعتدرت عن ما اعتبرته عن سوريا
المساله اكثر من عنصريه ان تشبه رقصات
برقصات القرده اكثر من العنصريه وهذا
الشيء مستعجل ومشيج اذا توقفنا عند لفظه
الرويه التي تحدث عنها السيد حسن اريد في
مقال نشر اخيرا كاتب دعا الى ضروره همم ان
نتوقف ونحلل مضمون كل ما قيل في كاس
العالم من قبل الاعلام الغربي لابد من
دراسات لتحليل المضمون همم هذا ربما يحتاج
الى الى جهد مضنيه على الصعيد الاكاديمي
ولكن الان كان اقدر اقوله كيف يمكن ان
نحلل ونفهم ما قيل في الاعلام الغربي ليس
بخصوص حقوق الانسان في قطر او العماله
ربما تكون بعض الاوجه من من النقد الخاص
بحقوق الانسان او العماله له وجهته ولكن
ما يتعلق بقيام هذه المنطقه وعاداتها
وتقاليدها حتى ان البعث شبهه بصراع صراع
رمزيات يعني مثلا همم هذه الاشاره اعتبرت
اشاره لداعش وهي رفع السبابه همم قضيه
البشت اعتبر مساله هجينه وغير مقبوله ب-
موضوع
الاشعه عديده يعني
تمام هو في نقاط اعتقد من المهم نتفق
عليها اولا همم لا شك ان الغرب ليست
منطلقاته واحده في التعامل مع هذا الامر
هناك من طلقات عنصريه صحيح لكن ايضا هناك
منطلقات عن جهل عدد كبير جدا من
الاوروبيين يمتلكون تصورات خاطئه عن
الاسلام يمكن تصورات خاطئه عن العرب هؤلاء
ليست مسؤولياتهم حقيقه ان ان ان ان ان
يعني لا يمكن ان نساويهم باولئك العنصريه
واذا كان كثير من المسلمين اصلا يتصور
دينه يتصورا خاطئا فما بالك باولئك بعيدين
والحقيقه انه سالب تواصل الاجتماعي لم
تقرب كثيرا عن المستوى الثقافي بقدر ايضا
ما ابعدت لان كل شخص صار يتكلم وكل شخص
صار يعتقد اليوم انه يمثل الثقافه التي
تحدث عنها يعني يمكن اي شخص مثلا من عرق
معينه يتكلم وبالتالي يعمل همم اشكاليه
كثير وانت رئيس ربما في كاس العالم انه لم
تكن هناك اشكالات فقط مع الاوروبيين كانت
اشكالات بين العرب ايضا هذه ايضا مثلا
تعيدنا الى ان هناك اسباب طبيعيه لانشون
مثل هذا الصراع والخلاف الامر الثاني لا
تقصد بعض العرب الذين تناهوا مع
الانتقادات الغربيه اقصد الاتي ان ااه
صارت هناك جدليه بين العرب والامازيغ
وغيرهم الاخره وهذه امر طبيعي مساله
الهويات مساله يعني سهله جدا التلاعب فيها
وهي من اخطر ادوات التلاعب يمكن لشخص واحد
يمثل اي هويه يحدث مشكله كبيره جدا عن
المستوى العالم العربي كله فهذه مساله او
الجدل في الهويات جدل طبيعي ان يحصل
والجهل فيه بنسبه كبيره جدا لان الانسان
مجبور على التحيزلي هويته هذا شيء الشيء
الثاني انه من الخطا تعميم الشاب بمعنى
شيء طبيعي يوم انك تجد مثلا شخص في العالم
العربي او من اي عرقه او من اي ثقافه او
من اي دي ممكن يتكلم بكلام سيء خاطئ ياتي
شخص اخر ويعلمه انظر الى الثقافه الفلانيه
هي تكرهنا انظر لك لا من الذي تكلم من
الاوروبيين وكان كلامه سيئا هنا كم عددهم
كم نسبتهم ماذا عن البقيه الذين لم
يتكلموا تعميم الشاد علميا خطا لا بد ان
نضع الشباب في موطنه اذا يعني عفوا من
الصعب ان نقول بان اوروبا الغربيه او
غيرها بهذا الشكل العام انتقدت واستهجنت
وهمم همم
هل فعلا اوروبا الغربيه في في الحمله ضد
قطر نعم وسائل الاعلام الغربيه معظمها
عشان حمله تجاه قطر ربما فقط ال- اوروبا
الجنوبيه هي التي لم تتدخل بشكل كثير مثل
ايطاليا واسبانيا وغيرها لكن بقيه وسائل
الاعلام خاصه المانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا
كانت همم نار حمراء علينا يعني في هذا
الامر الامر الاخر ان النقد بحدها لا يجوز
ان يكون لا يصح ان يكون لدينا حساسيه منه
نعم لدينا همم لدينا نقص في قطر وفي دول
الخليج وفي العالم العربي بشكل عام يستحق
انه انتقاد لها ويجب علينا ان نرخي الاذان
لسماع هذه الانتقادات سواء جاءت من
الاوروبيين او جاءت من غير الاوروبيين
لدينا همم تقسيرات في التعامل نحن اصلا
عنصريه ليس كذلك لدينا في الخليج عنصريه
كبيره جدا في العالم العربي
الثقافه الاخرى كيف ننظر الناس يعني في
بعض الثقافات نحن نعرف كيف ننظر اليها
ونحن اصلا مجهولون على التعامل مع
الاوروبي بتعامل من غيره يعني لما ياتينا
مسلم مثلا من شرق اسيا نتعامل معه بطريقه
الدونيه لكن لما ياتينا اوروبي لا
ننبهر فيه ثم بعد ذلك نجوم الاوروبي على
انه يتعامل معنا بعنصريه المفروض ان لهم
انفسنا في كيفيه نظرتنا للاخرين في كيفيه
رؤيتنا للاخرين عندنا مشاكل على المستوى
العنصريه عندنا المشاكل على المستوى
القاني القوانين يعني حتى القوانين
المتعلقه باقامه المقيمين اليوم نحن لدينا
معظم الخليج هو مقيمون طريقه التعامل معهم
ايضا ليست سليمه نحن ننتقد الغربيين عليهم
ينظرون الينا بهذه النظر لكن نحن كيف ننظر
للمقيمين الذين يعيشون في بلداننا لدينا
بعض القوانين محرجه الواحد يخرج ان يتكلم
عنها ومع ذلك ما لا نتكلم عنها نحتاج كما
ان ننتقد الغرب ان ننتقد ذاتنا في هذا
الامر لذلك لا ينبغي ان تكون هناك حساسيه
لما نستمع الى النقد الاوروبي بس المشكله
ان اوروبي لا ياتينا هناك كده ياتينا
معلما سيدا يريد ان يفرض لو جاءنا على
سبيل همم الحوار القائم على الاحترام
المتبادل اهلا وسهلا به
لماذا لدينا من اخطاء لديكم انتم والله في
ثقافتكم العربيه الخطا الفلاني الفلاني عن
العيون تناقش فيه انت ترى ان الشدود الحق
وترى هذا الحق وترى هذا تعال نتكلم من
مصدر الحق ما هو معيار الحكم ما طبيعه
الحق ده على الجدال يكون علميا في هذا
الامر لكن للاسف هذا ايضا تتحمله دوالنا
للاسف ماذا ماذا عقد الدول الخليج سابقا
فيما يتعلق بتطوير الحوار
حتى الذين جاءوا الى هنا يعني ساهموا في
تعديل وكيف ترى سيدتنا همم تاثير
السياسيين او تاثر السياسيين بكل هذا
الجدل يعني مثلا على سبيل المثال السفير
الالماني هنا في قطر ارسل بمذكره قيلت
بانها السريه ولكن نشرت في ال- في الصحافه
يلوم الحكومه يقول انتم بدكم رصيدا
المانيا كان جيدا همم مثل هذه التعليق همم
مكرونه بعد حمله صحفيه فرنسيه ودعوه الى
شبه مقاطعه المونديال
هاتف امير قطر مستشار الالماني ايضا فعل
ماكرون جاء الى هنا هل تعتقد بان
السياسيين شعروا بان
الانعكاس سلبي وعليهم ان يتلافوا
التداعيات السلبيه
من الذي يربح وهو يتربح من وراءه مثل هذه
السرديات فليس كل التقارير الاعلاميه كان
سلبيا كانت هناك ايضا
وافلام وثائقيه اظهرت الجانبه الايجابيه
لقطر المنطقه اعتقد بعد كل هذا وذاك اذا
ما لقينا نظره
حسام حسني في البنك
الحدث ان الحدث كانت له
تداعيات ايجابيه واعتقد ان
المزيد من الالمان بعته يدركون على
حساسيات العلاقات الدوليه وما يشوبها من
امور هذه الصوره الايجابيه يا دكتور حسن
اريد التي بدات تعكس الصوره السلبيه سواء
خلال المونديال او الان البعض عائله ما
سماه تثير تثمير الايجابيات يعني الصوره
همم تم ارجوا ان تكون تسمعوا الان تسمعوني
سعيده
البعض عائله تثمير الايجابيات بمعنى ان
صحيح كانت هناك انتقادات ولكن هذه
الانتقادات تم تعديلها رويدا رويدا بفعل
انطباعات خلال المونديال والان علينا ان
نبني على هذه الايجابيات سؤالي هو هل يمكن
فعلا ان نثمر هذه الايجابيات بمعنى ان
نبدا ونشرع في الانطلاق مما حدث لي تغيير
صوره نمطيه للاسف لم تكن همم يعني كانت
منتشره يعني
هو الشيء هو انه مونديال تظاهر رياضيه
وينبغي ان تقاس بمعايا رياضيه
وغالب بالانتقادات كانت مغرضه لاسباب لا
علاقه له بالرياضه يعني مثل
اتهم قطر بالارهاب قبل العقاد المونديال
او اشياء اخرى لا علاقه له بالرياضه مثل
الدفاع بين قوسين عن حقوق المثليين همم
كان يمكن ان تعب او يعاب على قطر لو انها
اخفقت في تنظيم المونديال
وينبغي ان ينظر الى الامر على اساس انه
تظاهره
رياضيه بالاساس وينبغي طبعا ان تقاس
بالمعايير الرياضيه والكل يجمع ان حقيقه
قطر نجحت اولا فيما يخص يعني همم
اول البنيات الاساسيه وفي ما يخص التنظيم
وفي ما يخص الامن وهو شيء مهم وهذا هو
المهم اما الجوانب الثقافيه
الموديل ليس هو الاطار الامثل ما معانا
نعم انا اتفق مع الاستاذ
النائب بان هناك مشاكل عده في العالم
العربي ولكن ال ال المونديال ليس هو
والحال انه مثل ما قلت في مستهلك كلمتي حق
او حريه التعبير شيء مكفول ولكن حريه
التعبير ليست هي يعني
الوقوع في في في احكام جذافيه او او مسبقه
النقد شيء ايجابي ولكن التحامل ليس هو
والحال انه حقيقه وقعنا في اشياء لا علاقه
لها لا بالنقد ولا بالنظره
الموضوع يعني كيف يمكن ان نعتبر ما قامت
به مثلا قناه المانيا حينما اعتبرت بانه
ارتداء ميسي للعباءه شيء مقزز ويبعث على
الالم واعتبرت كلمه الالم يعني يمكن ان
افهم انه انها قالت تختلف اولها وجهه نظر
او شيء من هذا القبيل وطبعا يسهل ان يرد
على ذلك لانه هناك سوابق مثل ما قلتهم في
مثل هذا الحوار بانه
مارادونا ارتدياه يعني سمبريرو قبعه
سندريلا
كيف يجوز لاشخاص او او لحضارات ان تظهر ما
يمثل جوانب ثقافيه وحضاريه
ويمنع من ذلك ولذلك انا حقيقه وقفت واعتقد
بان حفل اختتام كان موفقا بالاستشهاد
بالبيت الشهير عين الردى عن كل عيب كليله
وعين وسخت تبدي المساويه طبعا حينما يرى
الشخص او يريد ان يريد ان لا يرى الاشياء
السلبيه
فطبعا سيركز على الاشياء السلبيه والحال
انه الان ينبغي طبعا قراءه متانيه للذين
يستطيعون ان يقوموا بقراءه متانيه لا
اعتقد بانه من الموجدي الاستماع لمن له
افكار واحكام مسبقه ايا كانت ايا كانت هذه
مذيعه من الوقت والحال ان هنا تحدث عن
رصيد وهو المهم هو نج المونديال لو كنا
قبل المونديال لا ربما كانت ستنتابنا شكوك
او شيء من هذا القبيل نحن في وضع معين وهو
نجاح المونديال بل نجاح غير مسبوق ولذلك
ينبغي لاستماع فقط
للرؤى الموضوعيه اما الذي يصدر من احكام
مسبقه ضد دوله او ضد ثقافه او ضد دين الى
اخره فلا اظن انه من المجد الاجتماعي
لا طبعا من دون شك انه الان نحن في فتره
او على الاقل بالنسبه لدوله قطر في فتره
ينبغي يعني ان تقف وقفت تروي والاستماع
ودراسه متانيه متانيه يعني
لكل الانتقادات الى اخره انا اتفق مع ما
تفضل هذه الاستاذ نايف منطقه تونات تحبل
بمشاكل عده ولا عيب فيها النقيب لكن نحن
نتحدث عن تظاهر الرياضيات وينبغي ان تقاس
بمعايير رياديات وان مثل ما قلت قطر لم
تغير قواعد قواعد كره القدم
احترمت قواعد كره القدم وضمنت الامن يعني
همم والتنظيم وهذا هو المطلوب الاشياء
الاخرى يعني هي بالاساس صادره عن مواقف
مسبقه ولا اظن بانه تستحق ان يقف عندها
المرء انما تخفي نظره استعلايه همم وهي
مخالفه للقيم التي ينبني عليها الغرب
النقد ليس هو التحامل وحريه الراي له ليس
هو القاء القول على عواجي عواينه
يعني همم
انتقاد مجاني لقيم وحضاره هذا مخالف لحريه
التعبير ومخالف كذلك للنقد والنقد ينبغي
ان يكون موضوعيا
على معطيات موضوعيه الدكتور بالنهار اذا
وقفنا عندما سماه البعض صراع الرمزيات
يعني مثلا الغتره والعجيال وانت الان معنا
طبعا بالغتره والعجال همم يعني لعقود كانت
تصور دائما في الافلام وفي هوليود لذلك
الشخص السريع الخليجي الذي يحب تبذير
المال ويعشق النساء ويعشق الخمره وغيرها
الان همم في المونديال مثلا اصبحت الغتره
بالوان الاعلام والوان كل الجنسيات وكل
الذين جاءوا وتمتعوا بها اييي قصه انه لا
وجود للخمر في الملاعب في الملعب وهذه
ينتقدت عليها قطر لكن الان الانجليزي
يقولون والله فكره جيده لم نشهد لا
اشتباكات ولا معارك ولا عنف وهذا وهذا شيء
ربما علينا ان نقوم به هناك مثلا ايضا
البشت ربما علينا ان نتوقف لان كثيرون لم
يستوعبوا الحركه ما معناها ما دلالتها كيف
يمكن ان نبني على ذلك حتى نستطيع ان نقدم
صوره اخرى مختلفه عن المنطقه
شوف قطر حققت مكسبا ثقافيه كبيره جدا ربما
قطر لم تخطط حتى لهذا الامر لكن الواقع
والسياق كل ادى الى ان تحقق قطر مكسبا
ثقافيه لكن الان قطر امام فريقين اما ان
يكون هذا المكسب الثقافي مجرد موقف عارض
او ان يكون نموذج استراتيجي بمعنى اخر هذا
الان التحدي الاساسي لقطر والنجاح الحقيقي
نعم كاس العالم كانت تنظيمه من الجيش وكان
متميزا بشهاده الجميع لكن النجاح الحقيقي
هي ااه او هو حينما تحول قطر هذه المكسب
من مجرد موقف عارض الى نموذج استراتيجي
الان هذا الان لما تتكلم كيف الان سالتني
عن قبل قليل عن هذا الغتره وغير الاخرين
ربما لا تزال تمثل رمزا للخليج الملف اليس
كذلك الان هنا التحدي قطر المفترض الان
انه حتى يتحول الى نموذج حقيقي لابد ان ان
ان يقوم هذا النموذج على خطاب فكري ثقافي
مركب
يعني لما جائتنا هذه الحمله الاعلاميه
الغربيه من كل الجهات التي ساهمت فيها في
اوروبا الغربيه
كنا محتاجين الى القانون الدولي كنا
محتاجين الى العلاقات الدوليه كنا محتاجين
لفهم الاديان كنا محتاجين لفهم الثقافات
الاخرى نحتاج الى خطاب ثقافي مركب يدرك
ابعاد المساله الثقافيه وهو ليس من جانب
واحد البحث البيني في العلوم الانسانيه
والاجتماعيه يعيننا على فهم
الثقافات الاخرى ويعيننا على تطوير خطاب
ثقافي مركب
يمكننا من التعامل ومن التغيير الوعي
الثقافي الغربي اتجاه هذه الرموز يعني همم
لما لما تكلمنا قبل قليل عن هذه الرموز
همم ممكن الى الان الناس تتصور بهذه
الطريقه لكن لما يكون لدينا الخطاب ثقافي
همم متمكن نبني عليه ما نستطيع ان نبني
كاس العالم لنا شيء انا اساسيا استاذ محمد
ان الرياضه واحده لا تكفي مهما كنت بارعا
في الرياضه واحده لا تكفي ولا السياسه
وحده تكفي لابد ان يقف وراء ذلك كله نموذج
ثقافي فكري قائم على خطاب علمي رسول مركب
يستطيع ان يتعامل مع كل الانماط الحياه
الثقافيه اللي موجوده في العالم سواء كانت
على مستوى القانون الدولي والعلاقات
الدوليه او سائر الفروع المعرفيه التي
تحتاجها ونحن راينا في هذا الخطاب يعني
نحن العالم العربي كله وقف مع قطر الذين
المثقفون الذين تصدوا للحملات الغربيه لم
يكون القطريون فقط
لكن الذي ساهم في هذا كان كثير من
المثقفين في باكستان في الهند في افريقيا
في امريكا الجنوبيه حتى نستغرب جدا ان
اكثر من مواقف مع قطر ثقافيه في كاس
العالم كان من امريكا الجنوبيه ويتواصلوا
معي عدد كبير جدا منهم هذا يدل على ان في
قاسم مشترك بين عالم الجنوب وهذا يحينا
الى مشكله دول الخليج انها دائما تلتفت
الى الغرب في كل المجالات التي ترتفت الى
الغرب لا يوجد حضارات بينيه نحتاج ان
نلتفت بعد كاس العالم الى هذه الثقافات
التي كانت وقفت معنا وكان وقوفها مشرفا في
التعامل والتسدي لهذه الثقافات العنصريه
التي تقوم على المنطق الاستعلاء
عفوا هذه المهمه اثقل من قطر
من قال انها ليست تذكره قطر قطر
يعني جبار يعني الجهد جبار وقطع يعني قطر
نظمت كاس العالم من يستطيع ان ينظم كاس
العالم من دول الجنوب يعني هذا لو قلت
سابقا ما في احد كان يتصور ان قطر تقوم
بكاس العالم ولذلك انا لا اعتقد انني احمل
قطر ما لا يعطيك حينما اطالب لها بان تكون
قائده لصناعه النموذج الثقافي بالتعاون مع
دول العالم العربي والاسلام كلهن تنظيم
كاس العالم كثيرون يقولون هذه اموال
وبالاموال بامكانك ان تصنع ما تريد ولكن
انت الان لما تطرح مشروع ثقافي معكس هذا
جهد جبار هذا لا يتعلق فقط بامكانيات
ومستشارين واموال الاموال الاموال تكفي لو
كانت قطر مجرد اموال ان الوجه لديها اموال
اكثر من قطر لكن لماذا لم تنظم كاس العالم
المساله ليست يعني قطر لديه خبره في
التنظيم والاستثمار من الاسياد 2006 وهي
تعمل على تطوير بنيه لكن انا اعتب على قطر
انها لم تطور هذا الامر قطر الى الان لا
تزال يعني اذا قررنا الامر من المجال
الرياضي لا يزال المجال الثقافي الفكري
ناشئا في قطر ليس بمستوى المجال الرياضي
انا الان ما اطالب به قطر ان تصعد من
الخطاب الثقافي والفكري ليكون سند لها في
طموح يا سياده ليس فقط سندر قطر لابد ان
تستعين بكل الخبرات العربيه والاسلاميه
لتطوير نموذجها الثقافي والامر لا يتطلب
كثير نحن ما لنا من المؤتمرات الشكليه نحن
في الخليجي بننظم المؤتمراتي ياتي
الغربيين في هذه يتكلمون فيها باي كلام ثم
يذهب بيتمشى في الاسواق المجمعات ويرجع
الى بلادي وينظر الينا بعد ذلك على اننا
مجرد منصات الترفيهيه مجرد محطه وقود لها
اكثر ولا اقل ثم انا الام الغربي بعد ذلك
اذا خاطب النبي خطابنا نحن الذين نتسبنا
في هذا الامر مؤتمراتنا كلهم مجرد مؤتمرات
شكليه لا تكون على المجاملات ولا نفس
البنت الثقافه والدبلوماسيه نعم في
الدبلوماسيه ممكن ان تكون بهذا الامر لكن
في في المجال الثقافيه لابد ان تكون هناك
مؤتمرات حقيقيه تقوم على حوار حقيقي ياتي
هؤلاء المتوقفون الذين يمتلكون رؤى نقديه
لنا ونتناقش حول القضايا النقديه يصحح لنا
ارى انا او نصحح لهم اراءهم هكذا يكون
العمل الثقافي الحقيقي اما ان نخلط
الثقافه بالدبلوماسيه وتكون المؤتمرات
عندنا في الخليج مجرد مهرجانات سياحيه
لهؤلاء الغربي او غير غربيه ويرجعون بعد
ذلك بتصورات سلبيه تضرنا اكثر مما تنفعنا
هناك مساله اخرى سيدتنا همم ربما لابد من
التوقف عندها الجاليات العربيه والمسلمه
في اوروبا الغربيه ابدت طاعات فن كبيرا مع
قطر
وامتعاذا شديدا من الاعلام في المانيا في
فرنسا في غيرها حتى ان البعض لم يخفي حتى
شماته اسمح لي بهذه الكلمه شماته في
انسحاب المنتخب الالماني او حتى في هزيمه
المانيا هزيمه عفوا فرنسا في النهائي الان
كيف يمكن لهذه الدول ان تستفيد من هذا
الجدل الذي اثير حتى ربما تصبح لها مقاربه
مختلفه في التعامل مع الجليات العربيه
والمسلمه في هذه قلبي نظره اخرى
لهذه المساله
تاثير
جماعي جمع ووحد العالم العربي العالم
العربي وقف متماسك
وفي لحظه تعرض فيها الى الانتقاد وكما قال
زميلي ليس من قبل الجميع لكن من قبل وسائل
الاعلام على الاقل الصحفيين لا يمكن ان
نفعل الجميع في سله واحده نقول هذا موقف
المانيا او هذا موقف الدنمارك علينا انه
يميز دائما نعم لكن في خاتمه المطاف كان
للامر تاثير وللاسف عندما يتم الترويج
للتربيه معينه يكون من الصعب تصحيحها
لاحقا لهذا السبب هناك حاجه الى حوار
تبادل ليس بين النخب فقط
على صعيده الجميع مسافرين رحاله مشجعي كره
قدم عظيم غيرهم من الذين يمكن يحتاجون الى
ان تلتقي افكارهم ليبقىوا ويواجهوا هذه
الحياه بكل تعقيذاتها امور مثل التغيرات
المناخيه على الاقل لا يمكن ان يحلها طرف
لوحده ويمكن لكاس العالم ان يكون لحظه
تاريخيه تعلم فيها البشر من بعضهم البعض
لكن ايضا يمكن ان نضيع هذا من خلال
التنميط واشاعه الصور
النمطيه واتفق مع زميلنا الاخر الذي قال
ربما ان كاس العالم ليس
المنبر او الناس او المكان المناسب نعم هو
هو حدث رياضي لكن للاسف كل هذه الامور
تحدث دوما لان هذه الطريقه التي يعمل بها
الاعلام وهذه الطريقه التي يستغل
السياسيون هذه الامر انا لا اتفق مع هذه
الامور لكن الرياضه ربما تراجعت كموضوع
رئيسي في كاس العالم هذا لكن بالنسبه
للفرق نفسها
تاثرت وتشتت انتباهها من خلال امور اخرى
وهما الذين
ربما
الدكتور وليد لو سمحت المشروع الثقافي
الذي تحدث عنه دكتور بالنهار هل هل من
السهل ان ننطلق فيه الان
اعتقد بانه اهم مكسب هو الانتهاء الى ما
انتهى اليه الاستاذ نايف بن نهار رؤيه
نقديه لذاتنا من اجل بناء لربما تصور او
مشروع ثقافي وهو الامر الذي ربما كتبت عنه
باللغه الفرنسيه يعني في مقال وقارنت بما
اسميته بندق الثاني
وقلت بان ما نحتاجه هو ثوره ثقافيه يعني
اتفق يعني لا يسعني الا ان نتفق
وهذه الثوره الثقافيه تقتدي اولا معرفه
الاخر معرفه علميه يعني سبق لي في معرض
حديثا في نفس الجامعه التي يشتغل فيها
الاستاذ نايف في مركز ابن خلدون وتحدث عن
عن علم السياسه وقلت بانه لا يمكن ان
نتصور عليهم السياسه عربي ينبغي ان يدرس
علم السياسه كما تدرس في كل انحاء العالم
لانه هناك قواعد
ناظيمه ولا بد ان نعرف همم الغرب حق
المعرفه واذا ربما حينما نعرفه ان نجري
قراءه نقديه واخيرا ينبغي ان نعرف انفسنا
ربما لم نستنفذ كل الطاقات الممكنه وعلى
كل حال الذي يمكن
ان ينبغي ان نستخلص العبره مما مما يعني
من المونديال لكي نصرف الاهتمام الى
الجوانب جوانب من الثقافيه من اجل نهضه او
ربما ثوره ثقافيه انا اتفق
في هذا الملحاء شكرا لك همم الدكتور حسن
وريد شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من ميونخ جيري مياس
همم
وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا هنا الدكتور نايف منها
شكرا لكم جميعا كالعاده ننهي بهذه
التغريدات ونبدا بهذه التغريده لخليفه
الهارون وهو احد الشخصيات المؤثره على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في قطر يقول فيها
اذا كنت تريد ان تعرف من هم الصحفيون
التافهون والعنصريون ومن يجب حضرهم فما
عليك سواء القاء نظره على اولئك الذين
انزعجوا من تكريم سموه لميسي في الحفل
الختامي كانت علامه على الاحترام والشرف
لكنهم ينزعجون من كل جزء من ثقافهنا
الاكاذبي لمرضي عبد الخالق عبد الله قال
البشت العربي هو تشريف وتكريم وهو رمز
خليجي له قدره وتقديرهم واصبح اليوم حديث
الساعه وبلغ العالميه عبر بوابه كاس
العالم قطار 22 ومن لا يعجبه البشت الذي
توشح به اشهر لاعب كره قدم في العالم
اليوم عليه مراجعه ازدواجياته وانصريته
وجهله بل وحقده على نجاح قطريا باهر
مدون يكتب تحت اسم توربو قال في تغريد له
عندما استضافت المكسيك مونديال عام 1970
جعله حامل اللقب بوليو يرتدي قبعه
المكسيكيه حينها اعتبرت وسائل الاعلام ذلك
تعايش ثقافيه لكن عندما فعلت قطر ذلك مصيب
الغرب المنافق بالجنون وبدا بمائر مزوجه
ونختم بهذه التغريده لعمر الريس وهو صحفي
مختص في شؤون الرياضه يقول فيها لم يكن
لدى ميسي مشكله في ارتداء البشت والاتحاد
كره القدم الارجنتيني ولا المشجعين ولا
وسائل الاعلام في الارجنتين وحدها وسائل
الاعلام الغربيه وعلى راسها وسائر الاعلام
البريطانيه لديها مشكله مع البشت خارج
فقاعاتكم الصغيره هناك عالم كبير حيث لا
احد يهتم بارائكم
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد الاسبوع
المقبل باذن الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]